i have to ask a twitter question okay
about aliens yeah you're ready this is
for twitter i'm ready what would you
expect from twitter can humans have sex
with aliens
and
yes um you could pass
i asked the language question can the
community communicate yeah
can they fall in love before before sex
that's how it works
so uh so which question are am i
answering the sex or the the love
um i mean
it depends what is more fundamental to
relations across
yeah across intelligent species yeah i
mean um
you know sex can mean a lot of things
um so i mean
uh if your production right you know the
the
when in star trek in classic star trek
you had to
to really
suspend your disbelief to to think that
um
spock was half vulcan and half human
right because that's just
not gonna not gonna work dna wise um
so um
so if by sex you mean reproductive sex
then um
uh i would say no unless
you unless you go to a panspermia
kind of theory which is that
uh you know humans were seeded onto the
planet as part of a galactic uh you know
uh
uh program of some of some sort
and then we're just returning home yeah
and hanging out with our
old relatives distant cousins yeah yeah
um
but that that doesn't seem
you know it doesn't seem
seem plausible we know that we know that
humans had sex with neanderthals with
denisovans denisovans
so you could think of them as aliens
that that came from our
planet
um
so
so that's a kind of data point i guess
but um you know if you broaden your
definition of sex to mean any kind of
uh gratifying physical
interaction then sure
right
dancing
and that's that's how we get to love
okay and love can take many forms
you